des barricades en feu dans le quartier
populaire de wanindara conakry la
capitale
tout au long de la journée des jeunes
supporters de l'opposant guinéen cellou
dallen diallo se sont opposés aux forces
de l'ordre sur les réseaux sociaux
le président sortant alpha condé qui
brigue à 81,2 en un troisième mandat
controversé a lancé un nouvel appel au
calme
j'appelle chacun et tous au sens de la
responsabilité et au patriotisme pour
qu'il soit possible après cette élection
quels que soient les résultats de
construire ensemble la guinée sans
exclusion ni discrimination de personnes
d'aucune partie du pays
c'est ensemble que nous réussirons dans
un destin unie et solidaire
je le rappelle encore la guinée est au
dessus de tout le monde
protégeons la dimanche dernier les
électeurs ont pris d'assaut les bureaux
de vote jusqu'à leur fermeture
mais les guinéens sont depuis dans
l'expectative pourtant selon les
premiers résultats du scrutin de la
commission électorale nationale
alpha condé donnés vainqueurs dans les
quatre circonscriptions sur 38 qui
composent le pays
le camp de l'opposition accuse de son
côté celui du chef de l'état de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour faire modifier les
résultats sortis des urnes en sa faveur
des élections qui se sont déroulées de
manière régulière
selon les chefs des missions
d'observation de l'union africaine et de
la cedeao
[Applaudissements]